[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin in allen einen schönen
guten Abend im Studio mit mir ist wieder
Katja streso später unter anderem mit
dem Blick zum DFB-Pokal und zu einem
Blick zum neuen Trainer beim VfB
Stuttgart guten Abend dann schauen wir
jetzt gemeinsam auf unsere Themen
Minister Habeck in der Ukraine er und
Präsident silenski wollen enger
zusammenarbeiten in den Bereichen
Wirtschaft und Energie
von Giffey zu Wegner CDU und SPD stellen
ihren Koalitionsvertrag und die
Ressortaufteilung für das Rote Rathaus
vor
vom Knochen zum Massenphänomen und
Designobjekt das Handy ist heute 50
Jahre jung
[Musik]
nach Kanzler Bundespräsident und
diversen Bundesministern war es heute
Robert Habeck der zum
Überraschungsbesuch in Kiew ein traf der
Vizekanzler reiste mit kleiner
Wirtschaftsdelegation an gemeinsam
signalisierte man dem Land Unterstützung
beim Wiederaufbau außerdem soll auch
eine Energiepartnerschaft wiederbelebt
werden aus Kiew berichtet Anne Brühl
schon der Ort ein Symbol
Robert Habeck trifft auf holodemir
selensky auf der zerstörten Brücke die
jenny-heft mit der Hauptstadt Kiew
verbunden hat ukrainische Infrastruktur
zerstört von russischen Bomben der
Wiederaufbau läuft schon auch dank Hilfe
aus Deutschland
sie sehen dass wir ein großes Volumen an
Renovierungsbedarf haben das heißt dass
wir natürlich deutsche Unterstützung
brauchen aber nicht nur deutsche
Harbeck hört zu fragt nach es ist seine
erste Reise in die Ukraine seit
Kriegsbeginn sie führt ihn auch nach
jahrhundert einen kleinen Ort in die
Russen zu Anfang des Kriegs besetzt
hatten
es ist ja nicht lang und deswegen ist es
denke ich noch mal zu unterstreichen
dass man dass man nicht vergisst dass
während wir hier reden Leute sterben an
anderen Stellen ähnliches Leid passiert
das
370 Menschen wochenlang gefangen im
Schulkeller 11 sterben die Leichen
dürfen sie tagelang nicht begraben
das ist sehr wichtig dass wir Partner
haben und dass sie das alles sehen
wichtig das zu sehen in solchen Kellern
zu sein und zu verstehen ob man der
Ukraine helfen muss
Deutschland hilft auch mit Waffen
seit einer Woche mit 18 Leopard 2
Panzern wenn man Frieden will dann will
man in Wahrheit oder muss man in
Wahrheit eine Ordnung wollen die Frieden
garantiert
und deswegen ist das richtig so schwer
die Entscheidung sind und so hart die
Entscheidung sind aber wir müssen uns
die zumuten sonst bereitet Putin einfach
den nächsten Krieg vor dass dieser Krieg
noch lange nicht zu Ende ist daran wird
Habeck in der Ukraine auf Schritt und
Tritt erinnert
die aktuelle militärische Situation in
der Ukraine ist Thema in heute live
gleich um 19:30 Uhr auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen und in der ZDF heute App
nach der Explosion in St Petersburg bei
der ein russischer militärblogger ums
Leben kam beschuldigtes russische Anti
terrorkomitee die Ukraine die Tat
geplant zu haben Moskau veröffentlichte
in diesem Zusammenhang ein Video dass
die Befragung der Frau zeigen soll die
als Hauptverdächtige Geld weitere
Einzelheiten jetzt von Nina lieber geil
in St Petersburg trauern sie um
einen Fans des nationalistischen
militärblogast
das ist schrecklich Terrorismus das
sollte nicht vergeben werden
in St Petersburg gibt es viel von diesem
Liberalen Abschaum der immer wieder
Kundgebungen gegen unseren Präsidenten
organisiert
Social Media Aufnahmen zeigen was
passiert sein soll eine junge Frau
betritt das Café hat offenbar eine
goldene Büste mitgebracht als Geschenk
für tatarski darin Sprengstoff
tatarski stirbt viele weitere werden
verletzt aus dem Kreml heißt es heute es
gibt Informationen das ukrainische
Spezialeinheiten in die Planung dieses
Terroranschlags verwickelt sein könnten
natürlich ist dies ein Terroranschlag
die junge Frau angeblich mit
Verbindungen zur Opposition wird am
Vormittag festgenommen Teile des Verhörs
werden veröffentlicht offenbar wusste
sie sie nicht wie gefährlich ihr
Geschenk war
Feinde hatte tatarski viele er war einer
der bekanntesten militärblogger des
Landes mit hunderttausenden Followern
forderte eine härtere Gange hat im
ukrainekrieg
so erinnerte heute der Chef der
Söldnergruppe Wagner im umkämpften
bachmut an ihn
das ist die russische Flagge darauf
steht in Erinnerungen werden tataski
was echt ist was initiiert lässt sich in
Russland kaum mehr sagen und so sind am
Tag nach dem Anschlag noch viele Fragen
offen
der Bundeskanzler war heute zum
Kurzbesuch in Bukarest im Fokus der
Gespräche der russische Angriffskrieg
schließlich grenzt Rumänien an die
Ukraine und dabei ging es auch um das
geplante Engagement des deutschen
Rüstungskonzerns reimental in Rumänien
gefreut haben Sie sich bestimmt auch
über das Werben von Olaf Scholz wonach
er sich einen schnellen Schengen
Beitritt für die Rumänien wünscht Wolf
Christian Ulrich
mit dem Schengen Beitritt wäre Schluss
mit stundenlangen Warteschlangen an der
Grenze nach Westen Zeit die auch
deutsche Firmen viel Geld kostet
9.500 deutsche Unternehmen sind in
Rumänien aktiv beschäftigen 250.000
Menschen im Land sie fordern Schengen
Beitritt jetzt
ein starkes politisches Signal das
Rumänien halt voll in der Familie in der
eu-familie angekommen ist und zweitens
geht es natürlich auch darum
insbesondere die Transportkosten lange
Warteschlange an der Grenze zu
reduzieren große Hoffnungen heute
deshalb auf den Besuch von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz in Bukarest ich unterstütze
sehr den schenkenbeitritt Rumäniens und
ich hoffe auch dass das in diesem Jahr
gelingt ich jedenfalls werde bei allen
Gesprächen die ich in Brüssel führe
dafür werben am Nachmittag treffen
Scholz und Rumäniens Präsident Johannes
die Präsidentin von Moldau Meyer Sendung
die von der EU Unterstützung fordert
gegen Bedrohung aus Russland
wir versuchen unsere
verteidigungskapazitäten zu stärken und
ja dabei brauchen wir Hilfe
Deutschland bereite Hilfe vor sagte
Scholz und verwies außerdem auf eine
neue rüstungskooperation mit Rumänien wo
an der Grenze zu Ukraine ein
wartungszentrum für schwere Waffen
entsteht noch im April will der deutsche
Rüstungskonzern reinmetall in Rumänien
ein wartungs- und Reparaturzentrum
eröffnen für in der Ukraine eingesetzte
Waffen es ist ein weiterer Beleg für die
gewachsene strategische Bedeutung des
Landes in Zeiten russischer Bedrohung
und Expansion
Schengen Rüstung Investitionen ein
deutsch-rumänisch moldauisches
Speeddating nicht nur mit symbolischer
Bedeutung
das Kosovo erkämpft sich die
Unabhängigkeit von Serbien 25 Jahre ist
das inzwischen her jetzt will in den
Haare ein sondertriponal klären ob
damals Kriegsverbrechen begangen wurden
angeklagt ist auch der kosovarische
Ex-Präsident Hashim Tachi als
Rebellenführer im Krieg soll er
mitverantwortlich für die Folter und
Tötung von Kollaborateuren und
mutmaßlichen Verrätern gewesen sein er
erklärte sich für unschuldig vor dem
Gerichtsgebäude demonstrierten seine
Anhänger Tachi gilt im Kosovo als
Kriegsheld
bei der Berlinwahl da lag die SPD
ungefähr zehn Prozentpunkte hinter der
CDU jetzt nach drei Wochen Verhandlungen
steht der Koalitionsvertrag wo man darf
sagen der cdu-vorsprung spiegelt sich
nicht in der geplanten Ressortverteilung
bei der Besetzung der Senatsverwaltung
läuft nämlich paripari beide Parteien
einigten sich auf je 5 Ressorts ins Rote
Rathaus soll der CDU Landesvorsitzende
Kai Wegner als Regierender Bürgermeister
einziehen eine Politik des Zusammenhalts
mit mehr Wohnungsbau und einer
Verwaltungsreform soll es werden Markus
groß
Extremismus das Beste für Berlin ein
optimistisches zukunftsmotto der
künftigen schwarz-roten Regierung hart
aber fair habe man gerungen die
Botschaft ist klar das wichtigste ist
glaube ich dass hier zwei Parteien in
eine Koalition jetzt gehen die ein
gemeinsames Politikverständnis haben sie
werden in den nächsten Jahren nicht so
viel Streit erleben nicht so viel
gegenseitiges ausbremsen sondern wir
wollen gemeinsam an den Problemen an den
Herausforderungen dieser Stadt arbeiten
mehr Leistung mehr Service mehr Tempo
die Verwaltung soll modernisiert und
Chefsache werden bauen ist ein zentrales
Thema das Ziel 20.000 neue Wohnungen und
mehr Wohnraum in kommunaler Hand die SPD
obwohl 10% Punkte hinter der CDU kommt
nicht schlecht weg er hält wie die Union
5 Senatoren Posten Franziska Giffey wird
wegen das Vize und vermutlich sind
Autorin für Stadt Entwicklung sie wirkt
für das neue Bündnis das sind ihre
Partei umstritten ist
wer gestalten will wer verändern will
der muss Regierungsverantwortung haben
und deswegen ist für mich die Empfehlung
auch dass wir jetzt diesen Weg gehen
dass wir diese vielen Dinge die
vereinbart sind auch wirklich machen
können und es ist mehr in diesem
Koalitionsvertrag als im rot-grün-roten
Bündnis möglich war nicht alle in der
SPD sind überzeugt Kritik vor allem von
den Parteilinken warum gehen wir das
regierende Bürgermeister in Amt ab plus
wenn man sieht dass die CDU noch das
sozusagen das Finanzressort bekommen
also zwei wirklich zentrale Ressource
bekommt da kann man sich schon fragen
wie sich die SPD noch durchsetzen will
die SPD-Mitglieder haben jetzt das
letzte Wort am 23 April soll das
Ergebnis der Urabstimmung vorliegen geht
alles glatt könnte Kai Wegener schon
vier Tage später ins Rote Rathaus ziehen
Finnland wird morgen offiziell in die
NATO aufgenommen das gab Generalsekretär
deutenberg heute bekannt und sprach von
einem historischen Tag parallel dazu
steht das Land nach der Parlamentswahl
vor einem Regierungswechsel trotz zu
gewinnen wurden diese Sozialdemokraten
von Ministerpräsidentin marien nur
drittstärkste Kraft weil sieger ist die
konservative Nationale Sammlungspartei
um exfinanzminister Oppo dicht gefolgt
von der rechtspopulistischen Partei die
finden
auch in Bulgarien wurde gestern ein
neues Parlament gewählt und das schon
zum fünften Mal innerhalb von zwei
Jahren einen klaren Sieger gibt es aber
auch diesmal nicht nach dem amtlichen
Zwischenergebnis liegt das mit der
rechtsbündnis des früheren
Ministerpräsidenten Borisov mit fast 27%
der Stimmen vorn knapp vor dem ebenfalls
pro westlichen liberal konservativen
Block
lange haben bunt und Länder gerungen und
gestritten wer gibt wie viel dazu zum
sogenannten deutschlandticket heute ging
es los mit dem Vorverkauf für 49 Euro
ein Monatsabo für den öffentlich
regionalen Nahverkehr gültig ab dem 1
Mai in ganz Deutschland aus Hamburg
berichtet Sven regen die Hamburger
Binnenalster hat sich rausgeputzt
zumindest vom Wetter stimmt der
vorverkaufsrahmen für das
deutschland-ticket ich finde das sehr
gut weil das vielen Menschen die
finanziell nicht so gut aufgestattet
sind ermöglicht wir mit der Bahn zu
fahren wo wir herkommen nutzt uns das
leider nicht viel weil das ist recht
ländlich gelegen und da kommt es
eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht zum
Einsatz in erster Linie gibt es das
Ticket online und per App Abo Kunden
werden automatisch umgestellt in den
Kundenzentren liegen ab heute auch
Formulare für eine Chipkarte wichtig
dass Deutschland Abo hat keine
Mindestlaufzeit bis zum zehnten eines
Monats kann man das deutschlandticket
Kündigen zum folgenden
das heißt es gibt keine Mindestlaufzeit
eines Abos sondern man kann jederzeit
wieder raus und natürlich gerne auch
jederzeit wieder rein ins
deutschland-ticket übernimmt der
Arbeitgeber mindestens 25% der
monatlichen Kosten wird das Deutschland
zum profi-ticket dann gibt es zusätzlich
5% Rabatt vom Staat macht unterm Strich
34,30 € pro Monat Studenten zahlen je
nach Kommune die Differenz zum
Semesterticket oder nicht extra
einheitlich ist die Regelung beim
sozialrabatt und bei Schülern beide
Karten kosten 19 € bei Hunde oder
Fahrradmitnahme gelten erstmal die alten
Regeln weiter
Hamburg z.B können Sie Fahrräder in
Bussen an Bussen in U-Bahn S-Bahn
umsonst mitnehmen aber es gibt eben
diese regionalen Sonderregelung und die
werden sie auch nie ganz auflösen können
weil wir kommen aus unterschiedlichen
Traditionen das Ticket gilt aber
natürlich überall aber erst ab ersten
Mai ab dann ist es gültig das neue
deutschlandticket
Saudi Arabien und weitere Ölproduzenten
haben jetzt überraschend angekündigt die
Ölfördermenge in den kommenden Monaten
zu drosseln ab Mai soll die tägliche
Produktion reduziert werden um 1,6 % der
globalen Fördermenge die Ankündigung
trieb dann den Preis gleich in die Höhe
das Barrel kostete heute Morgen rund 8%
mehr als noch am Freitag damit dürften
dann auch die Spritpreise die zuletzt
gesunken waren wieder anziehen
die einen lieben Ihnen die anderen eher
nicht am E-Scooter scheiden sich die
Geister auch in der französischen
Hauptstadt Paris dort hatten sie jetzt
die Wahl und stimmten mit großer
Mehrheit für das aus der mitroller
allerdings haben sich nicht einmal 8%
der Wahlberechtigten beteiligt private
E-Roller bleiben erlaubt Thomas Walde
dagegen fast 9 von 10 abgegebenen
Stimmen wollen das Ende der E-Roller in
der Stadt zwar ging nicht einmal jeder
zwölfte an die Urne aber die
Bürgermeisterin von Paris will das
Ergebnis umsetzen die Pariser haben uns
einen klaren weggewiesen und wir werden
Ihre Entscheidung folgen die Reaktion
auf den Straßen heute entsprachen der
Abstimmung gestern Nutzer gegen nicht
Nutzer jung gegen alt App gegen analog
was für ein Mist ich bin enttäuscht denn
ich brauche sie um zur Schule zu gehen
und für vieles andere
es haben viele abgestimmt die sie gar
nicht nutzen aber ich selbst habe nicht
abgestimmt
es gibt E-Roller die mich beim Gehen
schneiden und ich gerate dann aus dem
Gleichgewicht
viele Pariser hatten einfach genug vom
Straßenkampf denn seit Einführung der
Trottinett haben sich die
Verkehrsverstöße Unfälle und
Verletzungen vervielfacht
die Verleiher der 15.000 Roller am Boden
das ist in jedem Fall ein Rückschritt
die mikromobilität hatte ihren Platz in
Paris eingenommen
der Privatbesitz bleibt erlaubt aber
touristen sollten sich beeilen die
Verträge mit den Verleihern will die
Stadt in der August wohlauslaufen lassen
heute auf den Tag genau vor 50 Jahren
führte der Erfinder des Mobiltelefons
Martin Cooper das allererste
Handygespräch mit dem sogenannten
Knochen sieht schwer aus war er auch wo
damals ca 1 kg das Gerät seitdem hat
sich die Technik rasant und digital
weiterentwickelt und bestimmt inzwischen
große Teile unseres Lebens eine schnelle
Kulturgeschichte über 50 Jahre Mobilfunk
von Patrick Lipke
Deutschland Anfang der 70er Jahre von
unterwegs telefonieren war für die
meisten Menschen nur in der Telefonzelle
möglich oder mit diesem 40 Kilo Koloss
so schwer dass er ins Auto eingebaut
werden musste in den USA zeichnete sich
derweil eine Revolution ab
motorola-ingenieur Martin Cooper hatte
ein mobiles Telefon entwickelt
man kann sprechen und hören auflegen und
anrufen
und mit dem sogenannten Knochen rief er
am dritten april 1973 den Chefingenieur
der Konkurrenz an
günstigere und handlichere Modelle
sorgten erst in den 90ern dafür dass das
Handy den Massenmarkt eroberte neu die
SMS führte insbesondere bei jungen
Nutzern zu daumenschmerzen
2007 unterstützten Bilder von
campierenden Menschen vor Apple Shops
das Marketing zum neuen iPhone
revolutionär Touchscreen statt Tastatur
Apple Gründer Steve Jobs hatte eine
genaue Vorstellung also die Vision dass
man in der in der Hand vielleicht etwas
hat was einfach nur Glas ist mit dem ich
interagieren kann was was hoch portabel
ist sehr persönlich ja und dann
zuständigen Begleiter wird egal ob Apple
Samsung oder xiaomi es gibt anscheinend
nichts was unser Handy heute nicht kann
Martin Cooper wundert sich mit seinen 94
Jahren wahrscheinlich welch
Wundermaschine aus seinem alten Knochen
geworden ist
allerdings wir sind jetzt beim Sport in
der Fußball-Bundesliga nächster
Trainerwechsel Katja der VfB der VfB
Stuttgart der tabellenletze hat den
ehemaligen hoffenheim-coach Sebastian
Hoeneß als neuen Trainer verpflichtet
und damit gleichzeitig die Trennung vom
bisherigen Trainer Bruno Labbadia
bekannt gegeben auch Labbadia konnte in
den 120 Tagen beim VfB nicht in die
Erfolgsspur zurückkehren dass 0:3 am
Samstag bei Union Berlin war die 7
Niederlage unter Labbadia in den
vergangenen 9 Spielen
und eben dieses 0:3 und alle weitere vom
26 Spieltag finden Sie bei uns auch
online und da heute.de und in der heute
App tja nach der Bundesliga ist vor dem
DFB-Pokal morgen beginnen die
Viertelfinal zum ein spielen die Bayern
gegen Freiburg und davor schon die
Partie zwischen Eintracht Frankfurt und
Union Berlin beide Teams sprechen von
großer Vorfreude aber spüren auch großen
Druck
Frankfurt Trainer Glasner und sein Team
in einer kritischen Phase 7
Pflichtspiele in Serie ohne Sieg für den
Erfolg im Pokal müssten kolomanie und
Mitspieler endlich wieder treffen gegen
Mannschaft muss nicht ganz so einfach
ist die klare torschossen zu spielen das
haben wir gut gemacht und jetzt äh ja
wollen wir den nächsten Schritt das ist
der wichtigere dass wir die dann auch
verwerten dass wir diese Effizienz am
Tag legen in punkto Effizienz steht
Union Berlin Modell für Frankfurt wenige
Chancen und trotzdem gut im Rennen um
Europa pokalplätze am Schluss glaube ich
schon dass wir wirklich in sehr guten
Tag brauchen und sie nicht ihren besten
haben läuft es wieder so wie im letzten
Bundesliga-Duell 2:0 für Union dann
könnte sich Frankfurts Negativ-Serie zu
einem echten Abwärtsstrudel entwickeln
ja und dieses Spiel Eintracht gegen
Union können Sie morgen live im ZDF
sehen die Übertragung beginnt um 17 Uhr
und noch dies der Deutsche Fußball-Bund
plant weiterhin mit Martina Fürst
Tecklenburg als Bundestrainerin der
Frauen-Nationalmannschaft der Vertrag
mit Force Tecklenburg wurde vorzeitig
bis 2025 verlängert also bis
einschließlich der EM in zwei Jahren
nächstes großes Highlight für die
55-Jährige ist aber schon die WM in
diesem Sommer in Australien und
Neuseeland und Ziel ist klar und Titel
mitspielen vielen Dank Katja das haben
wir auch noch nach frostiger Nacht
morgen wieder häufig sonnig und wo nicht
das erfahren Sie gleich von Katja
horneffer
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck ab 21:45 Uhr
im heute journal Interview mit Christian
Sievers das war's von uns schönen Dank
schönen Abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend die letzten Reste der
dichteren Wolken die hielten sich hier
noch am alten Rand dann gab es aber
heute viele Quellwolken die zogen von
Ost nach West über uns hinweg sie
brachten aber fast kein Nieselregen oder
fast keine Schneeflocke mit und das wird
auch heute Nacht der Fall sein meist ist
der Himmel klar nur selten reicht's mir
für einen Schneeschauer im Erzgebirge im
Vogtland vielleicht oder auch am
Alpenrand es ist häufig klar und so wird
es kalt die Temperaturen sinken hier in
Ostfriesland auf null Grad und bis -7
Grad am Alpenrand wenn sie empfindliche
Pflanzen haben dann sollten Sie diese
irgendwie schützen auch morgen bleibt es
kalt in den östlichen Mittelgebirge und
den Berchtesgadener Land steigen die
Werte nur so auf zwei bis vier Grad
sonst werden fünf bis acht Grad erreicht
und nur am Rhein reicht es vielleicht
für zwei stellige Zehen oder 11 Grad
morgen wird es zwischen dem Oberrhein
und dem Allgäu am sonnigsten sein sonst
gibt's einige Wolkenfelder im Osten sind
die auch mal dichter und am Nachmittag
kann es mal für etwas Regen oder für
etwas Schnee reichen bei Nordostwind am
Mittwoch wird sich an diesem Wetter noch
wenig ändern am Donnerstag wird dann im
Nordwesten etwas unbeständiger dafür
aber zum Karfreitag auch Bilder guten
Abend